Florence Nightingale on big data it
might sound like a random pairing like
Mary Curie on Wikileaks or Charles
Dickens on twerking but it isn't we know
her as a nurse the lady with the lamp
gliding through blood-soaked army
hospitals but maybe we should call her
the lady with the bar chart because she
was at least as illuminating in the
world of statistics so what would she
think of baby data
Florence loved statistics she said she
found them more enlivening than a novel
and a friend said however exhausted
Florence might be the site of long
columns of figures was perfectly
reviving to her for Florence statistics
were God's work she said to understand
God's thoughts we must study statistics
for these are the measure of his purpose
so although she's famous now as a nurse
she actually trained first as a
statistician it wasn't until the
beginning of the 1840s when she was in
her early 20s and saw hunger and
unemployment all around her that she
became a nurse she'd combined her
nursing and statistics to become an
experienced hospital manager just in
time for the Crimean War at the time
nurses were seen as ignorant and
lower-class but Florence changed that
Florence volunteered to lead a team of
nurses in the war before she arrived the
military hospitals didn't even bother to
record many of the deaths
Florence collected data about everything
so she could show that changes in diet
and sanitation had brought the
hospital's death rate down from 42
percent to just 2%
it's only when you gather data
methodically that patterns emerge things
that were hidden suddenly become clear
that might sound obvious now but it
wasn't back then
Frances work made a huge impact and laid
the groundwork for things we now take
for granted like being able to compare
hospitals performance or just the fact
that hospitals are clean
Florence showed what could be achieved
by following the evidence instead of gut
instinct prejudice or tradition another
little-known side of Florence is her
talent for infographics she turned data
into pictures making it impossible for
MPs and civil servants to ignore so she
would love the data journalism we have
today she would love the way big data
makes all this possible but she it hates
some of the ways that data are abused
she knew that people can game the system
to make the performance indicators look
better so when you hear of hospitals
fiddling operation waiting times think
of Florence and I think she'd be
appalled and using data to target
adverts and manipulate people on social
media this would not be God's work
although largely confined to her room
for over half a century she worked
tirelessly behind the scenes in
coordinating campaigns and she always
had a careful media strategy so I think
she might like other aspects of social
media she'd enjoy the opportunity to
communicate on a grand scale with ideas
going viral and so many people being
able to take part in the debate her
compassion brought her fame and she used
that Fame ruthlessly along with her
incredible intellect to save lives on an
unprecedented scale if she were alive
now she'd challenge us to do the same to
look at how we can use the vast amount
of data now available to save lives
to make the world a better place to
shine a little more light on us all
thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon